hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for this video
where I'm going to talk about a special
feature on orderflows Trader that uh
detects Market weakness in the market by
reading the order flow and why is you
know Market weakness important is
because you know these are often great
turning points in the market okay now
before we jump in you know if you enjoy
my videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell so you don't miss
any new upload and if you find the
information you learn in here helpful be
sure to leave a comment down below and
you know what if you want to get the
software there's a link Down Below in
the description all right so what are
reasons for Market weakness well
basically you know it could be profit
taking Market could be tired could be
showing some signs of exhaustion um
overextension you know on a move that's
gone too far too fast and sometimes you
know it can be hitting support or
resistance levels okay and you know if
you're looking at a a chart whether it's
a footprint chart or any other chart you
know a bar chart for example you know of
times you're going to wonder why did the
market you know trade up to here and
then sell off right it got all the way
up to 34 then sold down uh you know down
to 25 okay um you know these are turning
points in the market right why does the
market you know sort of trading back and
forth here then it pops up you know
basically from um you know 30 and A2 up
to that that high at 34 and then reverse
and goes down well Market is often
showing what we call Market weakness now
I know the the term on the surface
weakness um you know when you hear that
term you automatically
assume the Market's going to sell off
but we also there's bullish weakness in
the sense that um selling has weakened
really when we use the term Market
weakness it it means the buying has
weakened or the selling has weakened
doesn't mean the overall Market has
weakened and it's can only trade in One
Direction which is down right if a
market is rallying but the buying is
weakening the market generally will sell
off and on the orderflows trader
software we have a tool for that it's
called Market weakness okay and you you
can find it in the settings under Market
weakness detector okay and you can draw
it out fixed or until tested I I like to
draw it out until tested which means I
have a Zone a line being drawn out from
that bar the high of the bar which tells
me hey you know what there was weakness
here and oftentimes that can act as a
support or resistance in the future okay
and again you could adjust whatever
colors you like to have um blue or
Violet and you can adjust the opacity
and the Zone size Zone size would be if
you you're going to draw it fixed but I
like to use until tested so it's just
going to draw it out till price comes
back to the those
levels okay so I've enabled it I'm going
to hit
apply okay and let it show up on the
chart now again you know the tools that
you find in the orderflows trader
software are tools that I use in trading
and you know that's the whole reason why
I develop the orderflows trader software
I'm not a programmer I pay a programmer
to put all this stuff in there because
these are things that I look for in the
orderflow and what do we have here okay
so here right Market weakness this is
bearish weakness that's why it's colored
I supposed to be what was that color
supposed to be like an orange but again
I have the opacity on so it's not the so
strong color so dark orange even though
it looks light orange and blue blue
violet let's say blue velvet it's blue
violet here right bullish bearish okay
and you often see that or I say often
really what you want to see it at is
Market turning points okay and so why is
this Market weakening okay well among
other
things if a market is going up what's
generally what's driving the market up
it's aggressive
buying okay so if you know what and what
is aggressive buying it's people buying
the offer taking out the current offer
and then trading the next offer taking
that out right and that's what
aggressive buying is aggressive selling
is the opposite people selling the bid
cleaning it out selling into the next
bid cleaning it out in the market
dropping further okay now where do you
want to see that though right you want
to see it around swing highs or swing
lows I'd love to say the high of the day
the low of the day but you don't always
see it at the highs of the days the lows
of the day so you need to um sort of
widen your net and look at swing highs
and swing lows now that's not to say you
can't look at it anywhere in the market
but I found it's going to be most
effective at swing highs or swing lows
because those are going to give you the
potential for stronger moves right if
you're trading anything in the middle of
congestion often times it doesn't really
go the way you would like it right just
just because the market lacks Direction
but when you have aggressive buying
weakening going into a swing High what
do you think you know that's going to
give you a great trade opportunity just
as if you have aggressive selling going
into the
low or swing low that's going to give
you a great buying opportunity why
because the aggressive Traders ones that
are moving the market are weakening
right think of it like a machine gun
right you seeing guys in the movie
shooting the machine gun boom boom boom
boom boom boom eventually they run out
of bullets and it's the same thing with
the market the aggressive buyers that
were in here lifting the market higher
have declined and it gets to a point
where obviously eventually it turns
negative and it's aggressive selling and
the market starts to sell
off okay
this is a e mini chart let's take a look
here at at some other charts M andq
okay M andq I'll be honest it's not a
market that I regularly follow but I
know a lot of my users follow it because
I do get a lot of questions on m andq i
I me personally I think there are
markets out there much more suited
towards order flow that move in an
orderly fashion that don't jump around
the way M andq does but I have it turned
on here right um let me just check
the market weakness detector okay so
I'll just scroll down here make sure
it's oh the market sweep Market weakness
turned on
okay let's see here I'll just scrunch
the chart to make it a little smaller so
what am I looking for it's that
Violet there was I saw one from earlier
right down here right Market went up
some selling came in it pulled back here
Market went back up actually made new
highs you did have a little bit of
weakness coming in here now again is
this a swing High you got to decide that
yourself um about earlier right down
here right Market went up Market pulled
back beauty is I don't necessarily need
to analyze every single tick going
through in the order flow to see this
right this is the beauty of having
software that does the the heavy lifting
so to speak for you okay what I'm doing
here is sometimes ninja Trader will
automatically reset the default of the
chart Style to Bar withd 100 right
you're using candlesticks which is the
max so you can't expand it anymore so I
got to change it down to 10 that that
just happens once in a while um I don't
know why IND Trader does have its uh
quirks you see here look at this Market
weakness right you went up to this High
aggressive selling coming in but it's
weakening going down and then the market
takes off again where does it take off
from basically you know 36 37 all the
way up into the 60s
okay there any more I like looking at
mainly during uh Us hours now let's take
a look at another market right this is
what is this Ultra bonds today okay what
do we got here weakness now I have this
one this is so you can see the
difference the opacity is set at uh full
opacity
100 right see so it's really going to be
blue violet and dark orange right
opacity set to 100
bearish there's a bearish one didn't
work out but again that was right ahead
of the uh number that came out
today there's a bullish one
bearish bearish bullish this bullish one
sort of went sideways for a
while but you can see right at the high
of the day so imagine that you're at the
high of the day and you have a way a
tool that's telling hey you know what
there's Market weakness here what do you
think the trade is going to be now this
is where it gets interesting okay
because it's one thing to have you know
tools like this like Market weakness or
whatever
um but it's just one tool right I mean
let me just go back here see if there's
any more there's one there okay
but okay let's just expand this out here
so change the opacity a little bit
here
okay so it's not so bright on
you let just change it back down to
let's call it the 25
okay what else do you have in this bar
when you start adding sort of the other
parts of order flow to
it right it becomes much more I say
alive but you know I get excited when I
think about it but what's in this bar
got an exhaustion print
seven right I did this video a few days
ago talking about exhaustion
prints all right now this one I'll keep
set at nine because you know it's
treasuries well it's Ultra bonds the
interest rate see right here seven okay
he's coloring it a little bit darker if
I wanted to um that's fixed right but if
if I wanted to uh draw it out here and
you know maybe give it a
different a darker opacity we'll call it
35 you can see how the colors change
right cuz now you're blend colors right
it's okay what do I got well I've got
exhaustion here because why how do I
know this's exhaustion
here cuz the color should be green if it
was just
exhaustion and if it was um Market
weakness it'd be that BL dark violet
color but it's this gray color right the
color wheel right when you mix colors
together you get different colors so
let's tell me if it's a color that I'm
not familiar with I don't need to know
all the combinations of of colors I know
see there should be down here I can see
the little triangle so it's telling me
green there's exhaustion
um the blue violet Dark Violet whatever
is telling me that there's weakness and
actually I got a bullish ratio here as
well 44.3 so I got three things going
here up up arrows triangles rather so if
I have sort of this combination of
things taking place okay that should
give you a little bit more confidence in
what you're looking at okay now I'll be
honest I'm not usually somebody that is
going to say well I got three up
triangles here that's got to be very
strong and then take a trade but when
you have this Confluence right when I
see things sort of combined um you know
with the order flow coming in at a
certain point right we just sold off
from the high down to the swing low
aggressive selling
weakening not only that but overall
selling weakening and you end up with an
exhaustion print to me that's bullish
information information I can trade off
of as opposed to just a normal
exhaustion print or a normal um Market
weakness signal okay so that's how you
can combine the
tools together in forming your own
analysis okay because at the end of the
day that's what you want to do you want
to form your own analysis make your own
trading decisions so why we give you the
tools with the orderflows trader so you
can
use um the software to do analysis for
you and then you just putting the pieces
together right you're you don't have to
sit here and say well is this an
exhaustion print or not the software
says it okay that's an exhaustion print
is this Market weakness or not oh the
market it is Market weakness because the
software is telling you I I could have I
wanted to throw in the word algo there
because you know that's the term
everyone loves to use use nowadays algo
I do have a software called the orful
algo by the way but um you know people
say oh the algo says
this no this is just what's happening in
the order flow okay I don't like to use
fancy words if you don't need to use
fancy words but when you start putting
it together taking in context of what's
actually happening in the market then
the market starts to make a hell of a
lot more sense to you as a Trader all
right so GNA wrap up this video I hope
you've enjoyed this one you know you got
you can understand um Market weakness
right basically Market weakness there's
bullish Market weakness bearish Market
weakness it's not overall Market
weakness oh the Market's weak it's got
to sell off what you have when I Define
it in the order flow is you're going to
have the bearish order flow is getting
weaker which would in turn be bullish
for the market okay where the bullish
order flow that's going through is
getting weaker and it's measured through
the aggressive trading all
right
so catch you guys on the next video if
you haven't already be sure to subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you guys
later
bye-bye